200 km de la frontière russe dans ce
camp de l'otan ils se préparaient au
pire scénario
celui que tous redoutent de voir
affronter une armée régulière grâce à
enfoncer dans plus d'un mètre de
poudreuse monticule
un exercice dans les conditions du réel
c'est l' extrême de l'hiver en europe de
l'est ce froid l'a2 à mu encore
les mains engourdi champions mais doit
par des températures négatives soit bien
aujourd'hui pour l'entraînement les
estoniens affrontent les britanniques et
les français ont établi le contact avec
deux groupes de combat estonia trop ce
le vrai ennemi potentiel personne n'ose
dire son nom mais tout le monde y pense
il faut dire qu'à l'est le voisin russe
est plus que jamais menaçants ici à
tapas en estonie cette manoeuvre annuel
de l'otan a aussi pour but de
l'impressionner de le dissuader
d'attaqué c'est de la prévention et
surtout on est là sur un dispositif non
agressif on est prêt
à toute menace mais on n'est pas là pour
provoquer face aux troupes russes depuis
2010 est les forces de l'otan en bleu
sur cette carte se sont positionnés de
manière défensive dans les pays baltes
la pologne la roumanie à leur demande
mais ces dernières semaines les soldats
russes multiplient les manoeuvres se
rapproche des frontières de l'europe les
mille hommes de l'otan 700 britannique
et 300 français sont comme une assurance
vie pour l'estonie et son armée d'
actifs de seulement 6000 soldats
sur le terrain d'entraînement les
estoniens sont mieux équipés plus
habitué à ce froid polaire
mais tous ces soldats sont conscients
d'avoir besoin du soutien international
notamment pour sa force de frappe
ils ont apporté ici des sharks que nous
n'avons pas nous entraîner contre des
chars est vraiment important et précieux
pour nous
mais maîtrisée de tels véhicules sur ces
routes enneigées reste un exercice
périlleux
[Musique]
voire très piégeux